[Applause]
[Music]
second time is up and in pushes it
through he's got two
good job there by Mark five of their
nine rotation players have been in an
NBA Finals one of them is Kevin Love he
brought the attitude today to shoot
around normally a very mild-mannered guy
pushing his way into the paint Lowry
leads it the other round transition
Martin three good especially against
good defenses when you pass up a good
look it's hard to create a second good
luck Lowry in the corner with a three
it's a drive by Martin Hereford was in
the way he shot talking six Tristan Tony
shooting got it I mean how great has he
been off the bench for the Celtics his
activity on the offensive glass huge
Martin Ramses right inside for another
two halfway through the second quarter
[Applause]
[Music]
in this series Caleb Martin
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
against Tatum with a sweet spinning shot
that goes right it's picked up by Jimmy
Butler fourth quarter underway outside
Martin
Caleb Martin is absolutely on fire